welcome to this video playing hoax oops
now not the colonel come please can
rotating me myself him playing hoops
from Hungary yeah I recently played this
guy I remember but I don't remember what
it did so we get we get a pretty rare
version of the sloth sloth exchange in
fact we're black has fee and shadowed
this is more often than not not a really
great idea to fianchetto fianchetto this
bishop because it mostly looks at this
pawn on d4 where is so not doing much
and b5 is weakening the dark squares
quite a bit so I'm trying to exploit
that 95 is debatable might might be good
but it can also help black with the
trades ultimately though the queenside
should be a factor so I wonder
no probably not queen bee three but it's
not really helping yeah I'm ruling this
to t 2 B 3 c 5 this is the this is the
way to go the okay if i go nite b 3 here
Queen takes look a 1 now I can do that
just just about but some it's a bit ugly
looking but seems playable so let's just
yeah okay these are all moves I like to
play a 5 especially it's nice and now if
i go to be 3a might have nights if form
but i have queen e one can also just
attack this pawn right how to see how
does he defended if I if I just attack
the pawn with the Queen rook be eight or
something but i still can take it I can
pile up your rook c1 and stuff let's
just pile up and not don't grab it's
difficult time anyway to keep his stuff
here Bishop AAA that shake a six here
take d5 actually or not let's check
Bishop g7 now I can take this it's a
central pawn so just take it
Queen has to go somewhere to a2 is
Picard Bishop e6 and then I mean I'm
defending defending a five from the side
from the with the rook so I can go all
the way back okay so here taking I'm
just taking right check with the rook
thank you and ultimately night there to
earn to cover cover a five so it's a
pawn that's nice and I'm not behind on
the clock for once I played quickly
Queen over to see for would be nice and
controlling the CFL that's also helpful
let's see if I go Quincy for he might be
a queen e for now maybe jab but rook
them sort is that helping maybe I should
just check the pawn down I could have
played rook c6 actually know now that I
think of it yeah rook c6 was was a good
solution okay he doesn't really have
anything great here I believe but Luke
c6 was still still far more
straightforward rook t6 as a defense
keeping things but yeah i come i do this
now or should I take the pawn I mean
this is not really an attack is
quadruped c8 know let's let's just let's
just do that it's just a far simpler way
to play
okay okay six roop see 895 hmm Jim
probably wins but I don't want to give
him any kind of counter play sometimes
this is the wrong way to do it that you
miss some something so where you say I
don't want to give him the counter play
and then all of a sudden he actually
gets the counter play on d5 know
trying to get the night to see 42 e fire
fear that would be good was he for b6
this kind of thing
they have a very decent control over
this position he has some he doesn't
have many active ideas at all
yes he doesn't have any active move
really
I don't I don't really see a move on
very difficult night vemos lanaya
Brooksie seven moving the rook has to be
has to worry about yeah this was a move
Brooks is 70 or not now it must be good
right yes I was thinking about that if i
should go Queenie 5 or not for the trade
mom check it is okay
winning e7 as well if he goes night be
five which looks kind of normal and I
have um let's see Brooke be 70 may have
to be seven probably night c4 is a very
nice move that protects everything yeah
not now but here i was thinking nightie
for g5 just trying to figure out oh yeah
him the beep owner I just hope that this
is not giving him any any counterplay 96
takes pawn takes rook be too i'm
promoting that's good yeah so let's do
that I feel that this wasn't very well
played technically by me he probably had
some kind of chance I don't know I don't
know what exactly but morning maybe
there was something could have taken
before actually this is now leading to
the mansion position where white is
covering everything now rook b6
getting getting this pawn no I don't get
it but i can easily improve from here
black resigns Jamie it wasn't very nice
fine was always some there was always
some kind of pressure the start is
really this is opening line where black
is suffering anyway and with b5 his he's
really willing to defend a weakened
Queen side with c5 all those those
square as a week and this this can be a
problem really long term okay he should
probably go a five this isn't a good
idea here this is this kind of thing
with Queen a5 he should play a five so
that at least two pawns on dark squares
of course i can put pressure on those
but this was even worse yeah when I mean
he even gave me this tempo am queen d 8
is probably better but this is is just
very nice if those three pawns they're
all under attack and white it just has
the much more active position the
engineer is already giving it as a
winner 1.3 which is which is almost
winning i wasn't i mean i like my
position a lot but you can sometimes
really bungle up things quite badly bits
and I'm just let's just see I would just
want to see if I kept kept the advantage
and didn't let it slip yeah I could have
gone rooks e6 earlier yeah the the
engine just wants to take on a six this
I had suspected that this is working but
I did not want to allow this I wasn't
sure this rook is kind of off side and
now
yeah i thought 'if I've whatever some
kind of thing that irritates but jar +
voiced the evil so it was possible I was
just keeping keeping things check
together and moving forward like slowly
and it seems that I did not did not give
away something this was an important
moment he cannot take because of
promotion so night back and now I could
have taken before immediately but this
is not spoiling anything now so it was
technically okay I could have won
quicker with just the the brutal capture
on a six but it's no problem with that
if we if you win with a longer taking
approach as long as it's safe and it
looked very safe yeah I hope you like
this game thanks for watching